so today was the first day of three days
of oral arguments over the Patient
Protection and Affordable Care Act and
today was in some sense the driest of
the days it's the first day it's sort of
the warm up and this was about whether
or not the anti-injunction act which is
this tax statute dating back to 1867
which says that you cannot challenge
basically cannot challenge a federal tax
in federal court until the tax has been
assessed and paid and so if the
individual mandate which requires all
Americans to fire secure health
insurance or else you pay a penalty is
that if that penalty is a tax then the
legal challenge cannot proceed and so
that's what the court was addressing
today is this in fact a tax and does
that mean that they're the challengers
have to wait until 2015 a big takeaway
from me today was that a majority of the
justices seemed unwilling to allow the
anti-injunction Act to get in the way of
the broader legal challenge there were
it with weather was Justice Breyer
pointing out repeatedly that well you
know Congress called it penalty not
attacks and that that basically you know
just because it sounds like a tax
doesn't make it attacks you had other
justices making similar in the solar
comments justice Sotomayor said
something to the effect of was in kind
of the problem in artful drafting by
Congress which I think we all agree is
correct rate perhaps across the whole
you know scope of this bill so i don't i
don't expect that this is going to be
the issue that derails the legal
challenge I think the justices the
government everyone's in agreement that
they want a real ruling on the
constitutional merits not on this more
arcane tax issue